i have a special quote quote i owe
everything to boxing
you know why and what that everything is
is my life
boxing saved me boxing saved me i
and i and i and i wish it can continue
to save me you know because
if i didn't have boxing and as
much as i [ __ ] hate it
i love it because it saved my life you
know
and so being in haiti right yeah and
being you know being
being still involved and it's like
you're part of it and it gives you those
you know it's like it's like me and
tyson are gonna
you know be us forever
you know it's like we're a handful you
know like but this is what made us
you know this is what made us man and
it's it's like you [ __ ] love it and
you hate it you know
you know yeah because obviously and i
gotta bring this up man because
obviously right now you know
you and canelo are beefy and uh
you're even you're even you know you're
even beefing with dana white and
rightfully so
no no no no i mean look this is what's
happening okay
and and and this might be my my fighter
juices flowing again you know and
it's like first of all you inspired me
mike because you know being what are you
56 mike
56 55 you know and looking as good
as you did against roy who's a a boxer
who's a
a master right and the and just for
coming back and doing
you inspired me so i said i want to do
it too
you know but in back of my head
my demons are telling me no you gotta do
it [ __ ] oh yeah i know how that
works
you know what i'm saying i know i know
your subconscious mind right
right yeah and so so the fact
i want to do two of these fights you
know
i want to go i want to do two of these
fights
and then guess what i want to do a real
fight
a 12-round fight with either floyd or
canelo
i never heard no [ __ ] like this oh
what's your tank mike we should take on
that
i want you to look in the cameras and
say that yeah
yeah i want to do in my third fight
coming back
i'm either going to call out floyd or
canelo
yeah there we have it there we have it
that's what i'm talking about this is
this
that's what separates oscar from the run
that's what separates you mike your
mentality i'm
so excited it's here they got me erect
[Music]
almost
you